we have looks like unidentified Rovers
approaching our position possible pirate
activity my name is Jed Smith I am a
visual effects supervisor at method
Studios Montreal
in ad astra directed by james gray rory
mcbride played by Brad Pitt is sent on a
mission to discover the source of this
power surge on Neptune we're talking
about a potentially unstoppable chain
reaction here uncontrolled release of
antimatter could ultimately threaten the
stability of our entire solar system the
main sequence that we worked on in the
film was the lunar rover battle in this
future the moon is kind of this lawless
no-man's land and to get to the
spaceship but they have to travel by
Rover from moon base 1 to moon base 2
initially the sequence is kind of this
full moment they see earth rise from the
moon and they passed through this cloud
of lunar dust that's hanging in the air
and then they get attacked by these
crazy space pirates one of the biggest
challenges on the sequence I think was
actually lay out the whole sequence is
driving right every shot is a different
background to create all of this
environment we had to basically create
an environment and then place our CG
assets into that and create a believable
world that would exist through the shots
in continuity James Gray was really
interested in making this a physically
plausible like scientifically accurate
representation of what it would be like
to be on the moon we spent a huge amount
of time looking at all of the reference
that we could find of the Moon the NASA
Apollo archives were vastly helpful we
spent hours and hours just sort of
looking at those photographs and trying
to figure out why do things look this
way like why does the lighting work like
this
why is there no bounce light like what
makes this look the way that it does the
photographs from the Apollo archives
were shot with like a Hasselblad camera
like a film camera that they actually
took on the moon and like had in this
sort of infrared proof housing they had
this sort of washed out quality a lot of
lens flares and a lot of flash blacks
and a lot of sort of high contrast we
discovered a few things like on the
earth there's apps here there's clouds
there's things that scatter light
through the air and if you look at a
mountain that's really far away they're
gonna see
sort of a lifting and blending all the
colors and that indicates that it's far
away on the moon that doesn't exist
because there's no air there's no
atmosphere there's no sky it's black
direct sunlight so the cinematographer
on the film had a great idea to shoot in
an infrared film sort of dual camera
setup so they modified an Ari Alexa XT
to shoot in infrared they took that idea
and brought it out into the dumont dunes
in Southern California and shot a bunch
of really great plates in the desert
they actually built these fully
functional pirate Rovers and lunar
Rovers and we're actually driving them
around with stunt performers in
spacesuits in the middle of the summer
heat out there pretty awesome basically
the process was to take the luminance
information from the infrared camera and
the color information from the film
camera and sort of align those two
plates and stitch them together to
create footage that looked kind of
reminiscent of the moon a plate is a
footage that was shot on the set of the
performances of the actors the set that
was built stunts that might have been
filmed all of those things that were
physically captured this shot is a good
example to demonstrate combining the
infrared and the film footage for color
if we look at only the infrared portion
we see sort of a black and white image
which has dark sky and bright ground if
we look at the film portion we see a
color image and what we do is we align
the film footage to the infrared footage
and we take luminance from one in color
from the other and sort of stitch them
together into one seamless result the
importance of the infrared is that it
sort of captures the essence of what the
moon looks like so the sky gets really
dark and dim and the dunes got sort of
really bright and luminescent anythi
real looking many of the plates have
plants and I'm the rivers that were
moving and you can see just by looking
at the terrain that it was on earth we
knew early on that we had to create a
fully believable photorealistic moon in
CG in order to sort of extend the
backgrounds and
to create a believable environment for
our heroes to be troubling through we
scavenged all the sources we could find
of the actual robbers driving on the
moon's surface from the Apollo missions
and we found this one clip of a very
excited astronaut like spinning a donut
on the moon's surface and it was kicking
up these sort of see shapes of moon dust
from the back tires and they looked
really interesting and sort of bizarre
the dust would sort of be kicked up and
fly like much higher than you would
expect him and would sort of trickle
down and dissipate and since we had to
add to dust trails to the Rovers in
quite a few shots we built an effect
simulation and Houdini to try to
recreate this effect you can take
gravity and you can change how intense
it is so for example on the moon and
gravity is about one third of Earth
gravity and then you can take things
like air resistance and turbulence and
sort of control them as you wish some of
the wider shots were shot in sort of a
slower frame rate to help communicate
the idea of it being lower gravity it's
been used as a cheat since 2001 a Space
Odyssey if you shoot slow-mo it feels
sort of slow and low gravity and as a
audience member we're kind of used to
seeing that and I think we believed that
we had to extend the world that they're
in so to do this we're otoscope all of
the astronaut suits all of the pieces of
the rover that we saw we had to create
mats for is they didn't shoot with green
screen or a blue screen which actually
makes sense the lighting that they were
able to come up with on the stage worked
really well to convincingly sell the
idea of it being the moon they had sort
of one distant light source on the stage
and no fill light so it was really harsh
directional lighting lighting direction
was something that we laid with a lot to
get you know pretty looking lighting
because like if you look at the lighting
setup here we have diffusion on the
light that's making it soft right like
the shadows are diffused and that's what
look looks pleasing to our eye if you
take away the atmosphere business direct
sunlight which is not the most pleasant
thing to look at so we really played
with the lighting direction in a lot of
those shots to try to like shape the
surface and bring out textural detail in
the moon
the visors are basically these
reflective surfaces that see the whole
world so we had to basically create that
world in CG and had the reflections onto
their visors so it was a huge amount of
work in addition to the camera track we
created an object track for the visor
surface so we had a representation of
that ncg and then we were able to take
that group of our digital astronauts the
CG Rover the match moved visor the
camera and we would take all of that as
a group and put it into our CG
moon-world that we built and we would
basically have that group driving along
the moon surface and then we would
render the reflections of that movement
just compositing the visor reflections
was crazy challenging and that's really
tricky because those reflections were
oftentimes over their faces as they were
performing so it was like recreating the
faces underneath those visors underneath
the reflections on those visors and then
actually creating digital double
versions of the actors as they were
performing on the Rovers in CG it was
acid Lee Kump Lex but I think it came
together really well in the end we tried
all of the easy options and none of them
worked so we really had to do it for
real and do it right to make it look
good
if one shot starts to look off it takes
you out of the moment right so it's
super super important for everything to
be real and to look real this part of
the sequence there wildung these guns
called stilettos me and my team sort of
imagined them to be these sort of rail
guns that would be electromagnetically
accelerate and he's really heavy metal
particles for cinematic effect and to
make the sequence feel dangerous we
added these tracer elements to the
Stiletto bullets as they came through
sort of like a really bright motion
blurred streak as they flew from the gun
and impacted the terrain around our
hero's VFX is all about cheating if he
cheat in the right way at the right time
for the right effects that
something that makes the movie better
one of the things we cheated was the
brightness of stiletto fire in direct
sunlight there's no way those things
would be back right but that's one
example of when cheated it achieves the
creative effect and helps tell the
narrative there's this one moment that
sort of shows the aftermath of the
pirate reverse crash on set they shot a
stunt of that Rover crashing for real
and they actually smash it into the
power station and there was this great
shot of the camera sort of sweeping past
the rover as all of these pieces are
sort of exploding and we added the CG
power station in the background with all
of the solar panels and all of the
pillars and added a bunch of different
layers of sort of dust and debris and
then on top of it all we put our POV
treatments of the visor and it's a
really cool dramatic moment
in the sequence one of the pyro vers
sort of collides with the hero Rover and
sets it into a spin and since the moon
gravity is quite low there is very
little resistance to the spin and very
little traction so there's all of these
shots of the hero Rover sort of spinning
and it spins out onto the crater and
then there's a point of view shots of
the spin the crater design was something
that we and back and forth on a while we
referenced several real moon craters
because there's all of these great
digital elevation data from NASA and so
the other open domain sources but we
ended up sort of cheating certain things
for creative effect like to create a
really steep wall that they could sort
of spin off of after they spin off the
crater they sort of escape because the
pirates aren't brave enough to follow
them and they drive up the crater onto
the Dark Side of the Moon so it's sort
of like where the terminator line
between daytime and nighttime is on the
moon at this point they've managed to
call in air support and so there's this
great shot of the missiles that are
launched from this other ace and they're
sort of coming up over us and the
missiles come down and for the shot Alan
Morris the client the effects supervisor
had this really specific and a great
idea for the camera move and we are
trying and trying and trying and just
couldn't get it right and it up actually
putting tracking markers on his bedroom
ceiling and shooting it with his phone
like you shot this great reference of
the camera coming down like exactly like
you wanted it and we were able to use
that and sort of match it really closely
we wanted to create something special
for the impact moment of the missiles
sort of impacting the moon surface and
sending up this debris cloud the effects
artist who was working on this shot
found this really great reference of
this science experiment where they were
trying to simulate what a meteor impact
would look like in a vacuum and it had
this really interesting behavior the
meteor impacted and then this debris
sort of came up in like this cone shape
with this core in the center and it
looked really really interesting and
fascinating and we were able to sort of
take that idea and create like a very
large scale version of it so we added
dust and debris and rocks and of course
this is a shot that happens in
the night time right so there's no light
and so we have this really cool idea of
sort of using the light from the
explosion to illuminate the terrain
around the explosion and like sort of
show the crater and all of the idea tiny
textures on the moon and stuff that's a
really interesting moment in the film
there's another scene in the film that
we worked on that occurs right after the
moon battle so in the sequence everyone
wants to go along on the spacewalk to
the other spacecraft and so Brad Pitt's
character Rory McBride volunteers to
come along with the captain those plates
were shot on a stage using wire work so
there were some performers in spacesuits
so for those shots we painted out the
wires we also built the Vesta in CG
because it was only filmed with a set
piece of the entry hatch so that was
filmed for real which was great because
it was the set piece that they were
interacting with the idea in the film is
that it was a scientific research craft
we spent a lot of time looking at
references of the International Space
Station sort of creating like this
modular design of different space
station pieces that would sort of hook
together I think there's a common
perception about visual effects that
it's glamorous and you know you have
tons of fun and you spend your time
creating these beautiful worlds and it's
really easy it's not easy it's a lot of
really really hard work like there's so
much love and care that are put into
those shots a lot of people just don't
know how much attention to detail you
have to add in order to achieve that
kind of realism it's a lot of very very
difficult work but it's fun I like it I
you know I think a lot of people in VFX
really like what they do and there's so
much sacrifice that you have to put into
that kind of work you have to be a
little crazy and you have to love it to
stick with it I remember looking up at
the sky when I was a little kid and
trying to like imagine what it would be
like up there so it was really fun
spending
trying to recreate that and make it look
as real as possible